five business lessons that I just
learned crossing 250 million in 2024. So
the first one was the cost of change. It
was the first time that I've actually
quantified how much does changing
something in the business actually cost.
So if you would imagine a straight line
right and saying okay this is normal
business activity right straight line is
going across. Now let's imagine we want
to change something right so that's like
our normal revenue but then we decide
you know what I'm going to change
something in the business. So what ends
up happening is this little line kind of
dips down and I've estimated just for my
kind of like this again there's no
science behind this just my estimate
that I get about a 20% decrease in
effectiveness across any function that
I'm going to change especially if it's
manual. Now if you split test a headline
that's different but if you're like hey
we're changing our onboarding process or
we're changing our sales process or
we're changing our outbound process or
we're changing our something that people
are involved with um we tend to get a
decrease immediately of 20% in a
performance. All right, which is pretty
significant. And so as soon as I
realized that we had almost this
guaranteed cost of change, which is
about 20%, I was able to quantify what
things were worth doing. Because if
you're anything like me, I have like
this big list of stuff where I'm like,
man, we need to improve this. We need to
improve this. We need to improve this.
And I have all these ideas of things
that I think that'll improve it. But
when I actually am honest with myself
and I think, huh, how much is number one
going to actually improve the business?
If I say, well, I think it maybe get us
a 5% improvement. Well, if I have a
guaranteed 20% decrease or decrement in
performance and I have a 5% incremental
increase in performance, do I want to
take a 20% guaranteed loss to have a
potential for a 5% gain? Probably not.
And so, what's ended up happening is
that there's all these little 5% 5%
little improvements that I think could
happen, but there's only like one or two
20 30 50% plus improvements I think we
can do in the business. And so what
happens is some of these things I just
choose to never do. And I'll try not to
stay explicit here, but some stays. You
just have to accept that the business
will not be perfect, but your chase of
perfection will actually make your
current business worse because you're
constantly changing things. But let me
let me spell this out one more level. So
let's say you have your 20% loss, right?
Now let's say you do something that is
good, right? And it's you know up you
start going up, right? 20% loss, it
starts going back up. But what happens
if you at the same time say, "Oh, well
now I'm going to start changing
something else." Right? And so
basically, you incur this permanent 20%
decrease because you're always changing
something. So you're always 20% below
where you should be in the business. 20%
is a lot. Often times in the business,
my business has done exceptionally well
and I just let them breathe. Because
here's the other part that no one tells
you. If you change nothing, you get
about a 5% guaranteed improvement. Think
about how crazy that is. If you change
nothing, you
justupup 5%. You can book it. Think
about GDP partially. Some people are
like, "Oh, that must be uh, you know,
that could be in relation to education,
which in the US it certainly isn't." It
could be in relation to technology, in
terms of GDP improvement, or it could be
an increase because of population, which
in the US there's no population increase
or not really. For me, I just kind of
see that across all businesses that if
you just let people do stuff, they just
get better at it, right? People get more
efficient at it. I'll leave you one
tactical framework that you can kind of
use to think through this which is this
is actually from the investing world
that I've borrowed as an entrepreneur
which is called ICE. All right. And so
it's an acronym I stands for impact
which is like how big that's that 20%
that's that 50%. How big of an impact do
I think this is going to make on the
business? Right? If I had to make like
if this works it's going to do this. The
second is well how confident am I that
it's going to work? That's the C which
is what's my confidence level?
So I got this big thing with low
confidence or this medium thing with
high confidence. I'll probably take
medium with high confidence, right? And
then the third is ease, which is going
to come into a combination of how many
resources are we going to have to deploy
to do this? And also what's the timeline
that we're going to have to do this on
impact, confidence, ease. And so we
actually do this like I have this
massive sheet that it's called growth
and I have it in all caps. And this is
uh this is how I like how I get my add
is I put it all on this list which will
probably be the second big tactic is
that I have every big idea that I want
to try and I have to like get it out and
spell it out and say all the things that
I want to do and I just put it somewhere
because the team can't handle the amount
of ideas that I have and probably your
team can't either. You have to just like
scratch that itch in some way. I do it
by documenting so I don't forget it and
then whenever the team has more
bandwidth I go back to that list and I'm
like all right let's order this. which
one has the highest impact? Which one do
we think is going to work? Which one's
going to be the easiest? We tabulate
those together and we're like, "Okay,
this is the one that we're going to try.
This one we know has a 30% shot or a 50%
chance increase." That's basically thing
number one. And it has I've tried to
teach this down our portfolio and also
what we do at acquisition.com is that
you just need to be willing to leave
some things not perfect so that the
business can incur as few guaranteed
costs of change. And when you are going
to make a change, make sure it's worth
it. So, so far, number one, we covered
the cost of change, right? So, this is
making sure that you are only taking
bets that have 20% or higher upside to
be worth the guaranteed cost that you're
going to incur. And the framework that I
use is ICE impact confidencees. All
right, so that's number one. So, the
second thing is I used to have this idea
about the virality of products. So, I've
talked a lot about referrals. I talked a
lot about word of mouth. And I still
obviously believe in that. But I would
say that I've I've had this big pendulum
swing in the very beginning of my
career. Uh, you know, and especially if
you're, you know, sub a million, you
just got to promote, right? You just got
to let people know about your stuff. No
one knows you exist. You got to
advertise, right? You got to learn how
to sell. Cool. That's zero to a million.
No questions asked. That's what it is.
Now, to expand beyond that, I was like,
okay, we kind of pendulum swing back to
like we got to we got to make it super
viral, right? Word of mouth is, you
know, the best way to to grow a
business. But I've thought more and more
about this and I think that it's a it's
an it depends answer. Now there are some
products that you want for sure to have
people who buy and then buy again that
you want them to, you know, reoccur with
you as in like if I buy a Coca-Cola
product, I might buy, you know, a can
today and I might buy a can at a
restaurant later this week. And so it's
like am I on a subscription? No, but I
buy again and again and again, right? Or
you have, you know, your internet which
you just never cancel out of, right?
Either of those are things that are
recurring. They have high revenue
retention. But that is different than
virality, right? That's very different.
So on one level you have does it stick?
On the other level you have do people
share it with other people. This is the
nuance of understanding that's kind of
shifted for me this year which is that
some companies like especially
B2B there's sometimes disincentives for
a customer to bring in a competitor of
theirs, right? If you service two types
of similar businesses, uh they have a
literally a disincentive to tell people
about it. like they don't want anyone to
know how you're helping them in whatever
way. Right? So that's kind of like thing
number one. You have like a negative
pressure on word of mouth. The second
issue is that not even if you didn't
have negative pressure word of mouth,
there has to be some sort of density in
terms of the frequency of communication
that your customers have with other
potential customers. So, if I've got a
guy who runs a a metal shop that
specializes in aerote tech, for that guy
to have very frequent communication with
other aerotech companies that might use
my software, my internal my internal
tech or whatever it is that I that I
help them with, why is he going to be
talking to competitors? And if he is
talking to competitors, like why would
he want to share all my stuff? You can
understand why sometimes it's not about
word of mouth. And this is just a nuance
of understanding that I would think is
kind of my belief set is broken because
I was very hardcore on like everything
can grow on word of mouth period. But
that's just not always the case. The
gold standard should absolutely be
revenue retention bar none. Full stop.
And I can say that with absolute
confidence. No matter what business
you're in for B2B, your B TOC, you want
to be able to get recurring or
reoccurring
revenue. But the virality typically is
going to be more on the consumer side.
So if you have a really good soda,
you're you as a customer is not like,
oh, I don't want to tell my friend that
this soda is really good. You know, I've
got this shirt. It finally fits me.
Cool. Well, do I know other guys who are
built more like me? Yes. Do I have high
frequency of communication with them at
least digitally? Yes. Okay, cool. So,
I'm going to have there's some viral
kind of coefficient there that goes in.
And that applies to also consumer brands
that are not tech. I want to be really
clear about that. Like for those of you
who have, you know, the drop shipping,
e-commerce, retail products, it's like
you still absolutely need to have word
of mouth that grows the business. There
are just some businesses that are just
never going to have that. And for
everybody, you want to retain. So, that
was lesson number two. from a tactical
perspective for that lesson. The big
thing I would just want to measure is
what percentage of customers that I have
at the beginning of this year that 12
months later are still buying from me.
That's the metric that we look at. We
have a 100 customers at the beginning of
the year and at the end of the year 50
of those people are still buying. So
this is you know day zero or you know
gen one whatever gen one and then
December
31 how many of them are still buying? If
I have 50 versus the 100 then I have 50%
revenue retention. Now you can have logo
retention which is a second nuance of
this. Logo retention is of the 100
customers do I have 50 customers or did
I go from 100 customers to 25 customers
but those 25 customers really like me
and they now spend twice as much. So
that's the difference between revenue
retention and logo retention. For me we
look at revenue retention because that's
what we care about. It's like okay if we
just know that these 50 now that they're
in are just going to keep paying and
potentially even growing between 50 to
100 next year. This is a monster
business. This is what we look at and we
obsess over in any business that we
invest in. Now, no matter what, you
might not have a viral product for word
of mouth, but if you want seven
different ways that you can generate
word of mouth, inside of the $100
million leads book, I've got a whole
chapter on referrals. And I took out the
things that were the actual best ways
that I have seen from a tactical
perspective. So, I say I have six kind
of thematic things are like these are
things that you can do to your product
to improve stick, to improve activation,
to improve the number of customers who
actually want to stay and continue to
pay with you. And then on the other
side, I have basically the tactics that
I have seen work best for me and our
businesses. And so these are things that
actually drew in referrals. So I have
this whole section on one side of
referrals, two-sided referrals, how to
ask for the at the right time. So timing
is a huge component of it, how to run
referral events, how to have ongoing
referral programs, unlockable referral
bonuses, seven different tactics that
I've used work inside of the under
million elites book. You can grab them
somewhere on my site or on Amazon.
Number two is making sure that the
highest priority for the business is
going to be revenue retention, not
necessarily virality because not all
products are meant to be viral. But if
you are in a business that is consumer
focused or something that doesn't have
one a disincentive to share and a high
frequency of interactions between your
customers with one another, people who
have basically high overlap so they talk
to lots of people who could potentially
buy a product. If these two things are
you have a high disincentive and you
have low frequency, then you're just not
going to have virality in the product
and you don't have to worry about it.
But if you do, then obviously you want
to have both. Number three, I've been
very obsessed with the concept of LTV to
CAC. I've talked about it a lot, which
is basically how much does it cost you
to customer versus how much money you
get from that customer over the
lifespan, specifically in gross profit,
not lifetime revenue. Now, the reason I
I like to always delineate this and I
say LTGP, which is a mouthful, is
because most of the literature that
exists on LTV, so lifetime value for a
customer, how much they pay you in gross
profit over time, is typically written
in the software world. And software
tends to be virtually 100% gross margins
in most businesses. Many businesses look
at that literature and then say, "Oh,
well, let me just say someone stays with
me for 10 months, they pay $100 a month,
therefore my lifetime value is $1,000."
Well, that's only true if you sell
information media or software, something
has zero incremental cost. But a lot of
businesses don't have that. If you sell
chocolate chip cookies and the cookies
cost you $20 for each of those $100
shipments, I mean, these are expensive
cookies, but let's just go with it. So,
this cost you 20 bucks for every $100
shipment, your lifetime value is not
$1,000. So, we have our hundred bucks,
right? Times 10 months. That's the
revenue. What we're looking at is $80
because we have to take out the 20 in
cost times the 10 months, which actually
equals
$800, which is our real lifetime gross
profit, which in the business world
sometimes people refer to as CLV or LTV.
They all more or less mean the same
thing, which is how much money you going
to get from the customer. Now, I put
this as a frame for the big lesson that
I had, which is in the software world,
the big rule of thumb is 3 to one.
That's the big rule of thumb. I actually
now having worked with a lot of
different businesses, invested different
businesses, I think there's nuance to
it. So, let me explain. This is actually
pretty cool. So, there's three
components to a business that I I think
influence that number. So, you have the
attraction component, which is, you
know, the advertising. How are we
advertising? How we getting people in?
How are we letting them know? How are we
generating leads? Then we have the
conversion, whatever your sales motion
is, right? Sales. And then finally,
you've got delivery, right? Or
fulfillment. How are we going to get
people whatever they whatever they chose
to pay for? Right? So, if we have these
kind of three functions, the extent to
which you need to have high LTV to CAC
is predicated on how manual each of
these processes is. So, let me explain.
If you have paid ads, which I would
consider uh very high leverage and very
like one person could write a gazillion
dollars of paid ads, high leverage.
Cool. That's number one. If we had a
conversion process that's through a
checkout page, so it's automated, then
that's going to be something else that's
going to give us leverage. Okay? And
then third is let's say that we have
software as our backend that has unlimit
like we have no supply limitations.
There's no logistics limitations and
pretty much it just works. If you're in
one of those businesses, then you
absolutely can be at 3:1 LTV to CAC over
long haul. Fine. You could even be at,
you know, 1.5 to one. I mean, it
wouldn't be ideal, but depending on the
size and scale, you could still make
money doing it. put $100 in, get 150
back, do it over and over again. If
that's only true for them, what is it
for a construction business? What is it
for a a plumbing company? What is it for
an e-commerce business? The other
extreme, I'm going to just paint the
extremes and you can kind of understand
the middle. If I had instead of paid
ads, I had manual
outbound, so outreach or whatever you
want to call it, outreach, reaching out
to people one-on-one with the team. And
then from a conversion process, I've got
one-on-one
sales. And then from a delivery process,
I've got call it, you know, concierge,
one-on-one or even many to one
services, then I'm going to want an LTV
to CAC ratio that's going to reflect
that. For me, if I had a business like
this, and this is going to shock some of
you, but just bear with me. I'm going to
want this thing to be like 20 to1 or
more. Now, some of you guys are like,
there's no way it's impossible. I would
say I've made the material the vast
majority of the material wealth in my
life at 30
to1 or higher and I've done it multiple
times and during those periods of time
is when a lot of the basically the
wealth that I've accumulated has come in
but in the times in between instead of
trying to scale something that's at you
know 5 one or 8 one I'm just going to
continue to tinker I'm going to start
I'm going to stick with my one location
I'm going to keep working on the model
and just keep tinkering with it until
eventually we get the economics that we
need in order to scale what if I'm doing
paid ads ads, but we do one-on-one sales
and we sell media or information or
something like that, then it's like then
you're going to be somewhere in between.
But I have this as my rule of thumb is
that the 3:1 only matters at the
companies that have 100% scale, 100%
leverage across all three components
here. If you have manual cost all three,
you're going to be at I would at least
want to be at 20 to1. I shoot for 30
plus. A lot of people can't even believe
that. Fine. So, you know, fit it to
whatever your goals are. I really do
believe that you can just keep tinkering
with the business, keep tinkering in the
offer and find a way to get it so that
you can have a huge discrepancy between
these two numbers because that's what
allows you to scale. If you want to
scale a business that's more manual,
which if some of you guys are listening,
78% of businesses in America are are
service- based businesses. So, this
applies to you. As you go into colder
and colder markets, you will convert a
smaller percentage of customers. These
are customers who are less likely to
purchase from you, but you have a bigger
pool of people. So, that's kind of the
trade-off. But when you go to those
colder colder markets, smaller
percentage convert, meaning it costs you
more to get those customers. Basically,
you sell more people. You're going to
have more infrastructure that has to get
built into the business. So you have
layers of management that will start
costing you and not necessarily always
be alpha. They're not going to be value
additive. With these two things that are
working against you, you have to have
this very large discrepancy between what
it cost you to get a customer and what
you're going to make from that customer
in order to weather that storm and allow
you to kind of grow into that sh. You
can almost like grow into your LVD CAC,
which is kind of how I think about it.
So, if you're thinking about this for
you, number one, know what your true LTV
to CAC is and make sure you're doing it
off gross profit, not off of revenue.
And then number two, if you want to
scale, make sure that it your your LTV
to CAC ratio is appropriate for the
level of leverage that you have within
your existing business across all three
functions. So, you might be wondering,
why doesn't the ratio still cover it for
a supermanual business versus a business
that's entirely automated? The main
reason is lumpiness. You have to bring
people in for outbound that are not
going to be proficient. So, you're gonna
have to incur the cost of new SDRs that
either aren't going to work out at all
or aren't going to work out in the
beginning and then eventually going to
work out. So, you have to incur that
cost. But imagine incurring that cost
and then also incurring the cost of new
salespeople who actually going to be
trying to convert those prospects and
they're going to suck and they're going
to lose opportunities and you're going
to be paying them while they literally
close fewer sales for you. So, you lose
twice. And then also sometimes you spend
all this money and time to get them
hopefully to be proficient and then they
aren't. So, they just lost you money
three different ways. The third uh
component of this is the delivery piece,
which is like, okay, I'm going to have
to onboard and hire all of these other
people. And if you have anything that's
like higher expertise, then forget about
it. It's going to take even longer for
you to both find these people and then
also to train these people up. But
again, recruiting itself can be a super
expensive task. Like there's recruiting
firms. And if you want to recruit a high
level person, it usually cost you 25,
sometimes 30% of their first year pay.
And if you're paying someone $300,000 a
year, it's like you're going to pay 80
grand just to get somebody, let alone
hope that they're proficient. And you
still have all this onboarding. So you
have this lumpiness of of people that
aren't going to be effective. And if you
at 3:1, boom, you're done. Like it's
there's no like that 3 to1 disappears
real fast. It's like you have this
lumpiness of like, okay, boom, we got
these new SDRs in cra like now this is
coming back up, but then this starts
growing down. So now like we start at 20
to1 or 30 to1, but it's like we kind of
it's more like a wave. like it it
undulates with the efficiency of the
business and how stable it is as you're
scaling. And the faster you're scaling,
the more inefficient it's going to be.
So that's why you need to have as much
as you can in terms of LTV to CAC. It's
padding. The third piece here is that we
just went over it LTV to CAC. One, we
want to make sure that we're doing this
off of gross profit, not revenue. And
secondarily, we want to make sure that
if we are highly leveraged, then we can
be at 3:1. But if we're low leverage, we
want to be at 20 plus, you know, 21 or
higher. And again, this sounds crazy and
unrealistic for a lot of people. I get
it. Fine. At the very least, be at 15 to
one. Please, for the love of God, I
promise you it's possible. You just have
to work on it longer than you expect.
Which brings us to number four. Let's
dive into it. Number four. I've thought
I've said a lot about this, which is
that the 1 to 3 million area is a
huge swamp, right? We call it the swamp,
at least at acquisition.com. and why is
1 to3 million so hard? Now, we've we've
noticed that it's hard. But we were
like, why is that range hard? Now, for
those of you who are like, this is not
real for me. I'm just trying to make my
first $10,000 a month. Just keep
listening because believe it or not,
some of these things will apply to you.
So, if you're at 1 to $3 million, why is
this one of the hardest periods? Because
usually from 0 to a million, you can
usually do it with like you and two,
three people. It's not that hard for you
to keep track of the team. You can
usually run very high margins,
especially if you're a sole proprietor.
You're basically just selling your time,
which is fine, right? You don't need to
obsess about your passive income before
you max out your active income. Good
idea. By the way, a lot of billionaires,
very high active income, FYI. Anyways,
as you're scaling up, that first, you
know, 500, 800, sometimes million
dollars a year is actually in some ways
somewhere more profitable than the next
2 3 4 million because you have to
install this level of infrastructure
because you're like, I just can't do it
anymore. Now, you can always just keep
jacking prices and that's fine and I'm a
big advocate of that. But if you're
like, "No, I think this is the price
that I want to service at and I want to
do more volume." Then you're going to
have to put put in more infrastructure.
But this is the math that I just
realized is why it's so hard. So let's
say you've got a a $2 million business.
You're right in the middle of the swamp.
Okay? And you probably noticed
anecdotally for those of you who are
kind of like in this business world,
there's a lot of people in the 1 to3
million range. Like a ton ton of
businesses. To be fair, doesn't mean
they're making$1 to3 million in profit,
which means they're doing 1 to three
million in revenue. Big difference. All
right. But let's say we've got a $2
million business, okay? And let's say
that they're doing 20% margins. All
right? So they're doing
$400,000 per year in eBay or profit.
Okay? So we got $400,000 here. Now,
here's the stick. At this point, for the
business to evolve, for the business to
level up, the entrepreneur typically has
what I would consider an impossible
choice. You have to choose one of two
things. And sometimes the option is
both, which is path one. instead of
getting more help, I'm just going to
work even more. I'm going to go from,
you know, 12 hours a day to working 16
hours a day. I'm going to stop taking
weekends off and I'm going to basically
get through this hump so I can push my
way to $10 million a year, which you can
do. It is
hard. Or I'm going to bring in somebody
who's going to help me get there and I'm
going to maintain a relatively long
schedule, but still, you know, not the
same as working 16 hours, 7 days a week.
Those are the kind of the two impossible
choices, which is like other person.
Here's the tough part. If you have
$400,000 in profit that's left over, if
you want to bring in a stud who's going
to really help you there, you're
probably going to be looking at
$250,000 per year in all-in comp kind of
at a minimum to bring somebody who's a
real star into the business. Let's look
at that in comparison to what the profit
is for this business. You're looking at
risking more than half of your income on
one person with the hopes that it's
going to work out. But what happens when
this person comes in and then they
aren't that good? They don't expand your
capacity. It's like, well, shoot, I just
lost half my profit for a year and then
I'm still not further along. This is why
this is the swamp. And I and I I've just
spent a lot of time thinking about that
because I was like, why is one to $3
million so hard? You need the help, but
you don't have the money to afford the
help. And so, you either just got to go
overdrive and go nutso mode, right? or
you make a huge bet proportional to what
you have in terms of net profit to bring
this person in. And that's why it's so
hard. And so, if you're in the swamp
right now, my encouragement to you is
this. I have almost always been the like
I'm going to go into overdrive and I'm
going to hire the person because the
idea is what if I just do things that
are more unscalable but still generate
higher profits for the business so that
I can afford to take two or three shots
with somebody else who's coming into the
business knowing that I'm not going to
hit it out of the park on the first
shot. I mean, if I do, I'm stoked, but I
want to win either way. And so either
I'm going to win with more profit faster
or less profit slower, but I want to
make sure that I'm guaranteed to win. I
kind of do this as a plus scenario. So
if you happen to be in that 1 to3
million range, it's something that we
know obviously a lot about with
acquisition.com and we put together a
scaling road map. So when we looked at
our whole portfolio and the companies
that we worked with over the years,
we're like what are the things where do
we get stuck and how do we get unstuck,
right? And when we put it all together
on a map, what we realize that it
actually isn't by revenue, it's by
headcount. You might be doing $1 to $3
million a year and be here, or you might
be doing $1 to $3 million a year and be
at level five product size, right? So,
it really depends on the nature of the
business that you're in. If you want to
know what level of the scaling revup
you're at, and more importantly, what
things we've done in the past for
businesses of this size or at this stage
to get to the next level, then you go to
acquisition.com/roadmap. You put in your
business information and it'll spit out
and it'll help you figure out which
stage you're at so that you can get to
the next level. On the thank you page,
if you would like our team to help
figure out which stage you're at and
those specific steps and personalize
that, we'd love to invite you out to
Vegas. You can book a call on the next
page and if it's a fit, love to see you.
And then the fourth thing we just
covered is why 1 to 3 million is the
hardest. And the main thing is is cash
flow and time. you don't have the time
and you don't have the cash flow to do
more work, but you have to in order to
grow. So, either you work overtime or
you bring someone else in to work
overtime or you do both, which is what I
recommend. And that means it's going to
be hard, which is why most people stay
stuck. So, that's number four. Number
five, so
2024 was probably the first year that I
didn't have FOMO. So, fear of missing
out. It is the hardest part of business
is staying focused. It's the hardest
part. The reason you you hear Bezos talk
about it, you hear you hear Zuckup talk
about it, you hear Jobs talk about it,
you hear Elon talk about it, like you
have to be incredibly focused on what
the points of greatest leverage are in
the business. The reason that this was a
big lesson for me, not the focus part, I
obviously talk about that, but I was
like, why why was this year different?
Why was this the first year where I
didn't have FOMO? It's actually because
the idea of rush is where the fear of
missing out comes from. It's the
arbitrary timeline that I set for myself
that I just grab from thin air and then
I measure myself against this thing that
I made up to make myself miserable at
all times from whatever success I'm
achieving. In thinking about that, I I
have I've coined the term for myself,
which is that rush is imaginary. It's
made up. It's completely made up.
There's only one caveat that I'll make
to this, which is, and if this is you,
you probably already know. If you have a
business that has a tremendous network
effect and there's a very small amount
of people, even a big amount of people
in that network that you're trying to
gather towards, then yes, it's likely
that you have a winner take all business
model and in which case you've probably
already raised a ton of money and you're
probably trying to aggressively grow to
capture that network so that eventually
you can turn something into a profitable
business. Fine. For everybody else who's
not running a tech platform that's
trying to build a network effect of some
sort, you don't need to rush. There was
uh Anie, actually I don't think her her
her episodes come out yet, but anyways,
I'm going to give you a sneak peek. So,
I was talking to Anie Trrog and she has
um she has nail salons, okay? And so,
she has uh one core nail salon that
worked really well and then she decided
to partner with other people doing like
three or four other nail salons. And the
biggest issue she has for growing right
now is that her partnerships are kind of
a mess. I'll just put it like that. Why
did you do these partnerships? She said,
"Because if I had more locations, I'd
make more money." And I said, "Why
didn't you just make more money with
your existing location, save up the
cash, and then open a second location
all for yourself?" The thing that I kept
trying to tease out of her is I was
like, "She was just in a rush." Like,
that was the reason. She was just in a
rush. There's no actual reason for have
three or four other different random
partnerships with each of these
locations. And the thing is is that some
of you guys are you do this. There was a
guy who was here at our headquarters
yesterday. He has a Tik Tok shop
management thing, right, where he just
like helps people start their their Tik
Tok shops for e-commerce businesses. And
he was like, "But I also have this brand
that I started on my own using Tik Tok
shop and it's doing really really well,
but I also want to start investing in
I'm like, dude, what's the rush?" And so
the counteraction, like how do you how
do you counter the rush? How do you
counter the rush? And I think the way
that I have countered the rush is to
look at the people who have the ultimate
version of my business. Who are the
people who are 20 years ahead of me?
What do their businesses look like? And
what's interesting about this is that
the vast majority of them have one
massive business. And in seeing that, I
was like, huh, almost none of them have
multiple massive businesses they
started. Elon is, of course, the one
exception that everybody wants to bring
up. And if you're Elon, you alreadying
know how to speak alien, so don't worry
about this video. But for everyone who
doesn't know how to speak alien, right?
for people who haven't just generated a
hundred billion dollars in a year. If
you if you haven't done that yet, then
maybe consider every other person on the
Forbes list that just did one thing for
the entirety of their
career. And it's like Basos has Blue
Origin. Yeah. After 35 years of Amazon,
you've got Mr. Panda still doing. It's
like, but wait, he owns he owns the
Cosmo. Yeah, but he also did that after
45 years of Panda Express. And Panda
Express is still his cash cow. Okay,
I've got this restaurant. It's working
well. Awesome. Think about starting this
agency, right, for to help restaurants.
It's like, dude, what does the ultimate
version of this look like? The ultimate
version of this look like either you go
all in and you build an enterprise
agency that only works with very large
restaurant chains and those tend to be
sticky and those tend to be valuable
businesses. But if you're like, well,
I'm only dealing with small SMB
restaurant owners for my agency. Show me
one one agency that service SMBs in
that,000 $1,500 maybe $2,000 a month
mark who has a $100 million plus
business. Even just re like revenue.
Just show me one. Why doesn't it happen?
Because it's a bad model. Every single
agency goes up market and they serve
enterprise and that's become really big.
Look at Ogulvie. Look at Veayner, right?
Like look at Neil NP digital. All of
these are massive massive companies that
only service really the Fortune 500.
Why? because they're sticky. Because if
you have volatile customers, you'll have
a volatile business. If you have a
volatile business, you're not going to
be able to weather the storms. If you
can't weather the storms, you're not
going to last long. If you don't last
long, you're not going to get big. How
do you counteract the idea of rushing?
You have to look at the end state of the
business. What is the ultimate version
of my restaurant look like? It might be
2,000 locations nationwide. What does
the ultimate version of my agency look
like? It might be Oglev and Matters,
right? It might be we're doing five
billion dollars a year. And let's look
at the number one person in the space.
If what does the ultimate version of my
lawn care business look like? Maybe it's
a franchise. Maybe it's you privately
hold it. But no matter what it is, it's
probably not three different businesses
that you're trying to say start all at
the same time because you're in a rush.
Because the thing is is that rush is
what guarantees you're never going to
get big. And I'm saying this because
this is something that has plagued me my
whole career. And so just this last year
was the first year that I didn't have
FOMO. And I was like, why is that? And I
just think that I've just failed and
messed it up enough times to be like, I
just have to stick with one thing. And
here's the up part about this. You have
to accept that you you can't sleep with
every girl. You can't date every guy.
Whatever it, you know, whatever your
your your preference is. The point is
our life is so limited. It's just so we
just don't have that many. We don't have
that much time. If you want to do big
stuff, you just don't have that much
time because of that. It's like you just
have to accept the fact you just got to
pick. And you could have had four other
timelines where you could have done each
of these other things all the way to
their extreme. But the likelihood that
you're going to do all four of those to
the extreme when you start all four of
them at the same time is zero. It's not
going to happen. The first business is
built on hard choices. Business is built
on the amount of nos that you're able to
make if you can't say no at the
beginning of like I'm not going to just
pick one of these paths. Right? One of
my favorite little definitions of d uh
deciding comes from the Latin decaderee
which means to cut off. Like if you want
to decide, you have to cut off, you have
to eliminate things. If you have three
different paths or four different things
that you're considering, pick for the
love of God. And the reason and the
thing is is that you have made up some
number because some person you know
makes a certain amount of money or some
person you know thinks that this amount
of revenue is cool. And so you're like,
why would it be cool? So I want to hit
that amount of revenue. And because you
don't know how to grow the business
you're in, you only know how to get to
$100,000 a year. You only know how to
get to a million a year. Only know how
to get to $3 million a year. Then your
way of growing is doing more $3 million
businesses. When the reality is that you
have to confront, why is my $3 million
business not a $10 million business? And
you have to figure out that problem.
That is the hard work. I talked to a
lady yesterday. She was stuck at a
million dollars a year for 10 years. I I
said, "Why haven't you gone to to to $3
million a year? Like what's what's
stopped you?" Because she had a very
clear model. I was like, "Why don't you
just double how much you're doing?" And
she was like, "Well, it's a pain." And I
was like, "Oh, cuz it's hard." Cuz it's
hard. She's like, "No, no, it's not cuz
it's hard." And I was like, "Well, then
why haven't you done it?" And she's
like, "Well, it's just like it's just
like it's inconvenient and there's like
it's more it's more time aotment and all
this stuff." And I was like, "Yeah, that
sounds like hard. Sounds like hard. It's
hard for us to hear that we're not
willing to do hard things because the
hard changes." So the heart is constant,
but the nature of it changes. Just like
suffering as a human being is constant.
It's not going to go away. There's
nothing wrong with you because you're
suffering while you're in business. It's
just that the nature of the suffering
changes. In the beginning, no one knows
you exist and that's tough because you
feel ignored and irrelevant. And then
you start to let people know about your
stuff. And then as soon as that happens,
you have a different kind of hard which
is that no one wants to give you money.
And then all of a sudden people start
giving you money. And then what happens?
Then people start complaining because
your thing's not that good. But all of
these things are hard. And so we have
this idea that it's this rocky cut scene
that we're going to be we're going to be
fighting. It's like we got to just keep
gritting through it. But it's like no,
we are so equipped to save our egos that
we will come up with a hundred ways that
our heart is not hard. It's different
because we're special, right? But the
reality is hard morphs. That's what
makes people get stuck is because they
learn how to conquer one hard but not
the next kind of hard. I think that a
lot of the hardness is is sometimes
learning to say no. It's learning to
focus. That's the hard part. It's not
getting punched in the face. It's it's
being willing to let one of your
children die to let the other one live.
We get the Sophie's choice. We actually
do have to do that in business all the
time. And so you have to accept that
there is a life in the future that you
will not be able to live. And it's
actually it's honestly it's acceptance.
And it's this has just been a re a
really good lesson for me which is like
there are opportunities that I think I
could crush and I think they're amazing.
And you know what? I'm never going to be
able to do them because I still have the
one that I'm working on right now and I
have to continue to say yes to this. And
by saying yes to this, I have to say no
to everything else. These have been the
five the five big business lessons that
I've uh kind of learned more recently
and I thought you might enjoy them. have
an amazing day.